the fact the slice is baked behind bars
gives it a unique selling point I want
to launch my big idea onto the market so
tomorrow I've decided to arrange a
one-off VIP lunch event to showcase what
the bad boys bakery is capable of and
try and sell the slice to a commercial
partner
let's get guys listen and learn your
skin don't get burnt come in come in
come in I'm gonna now test you like
never before we're gonna cook restaurant
standard food and we were set up a
50-seat restaurant upstairs in the
chapel I'm gonna cook for some serious
individuals and we going up a notch at
big time my guest 50 influential
catering industry bigwigs including
major players from the fast-growing
coffee shop sector potential customers
for the slice it's time to shine
once these industry bigwigs are through
the door my plan is to first schmooze
them with three courses of restaurant
quality food now we're not cooking this
we're serious
main course the bad boys bakery take on
beef wellington made with the best
Phyllis steak and wrapped with Parma ham
and a savory crepe I want them thin
almost like a little little pair of
knickers Anthony yeah Finn what was last
time you had to pair them in your hand
yeah yeah Jesus that first night when
you get out big man pace yourself pace
yourself my son think about it having
dinner starter main course dessert to
demonstrate the professionalism of my
team
the Wellington has to be cooked to
perfection let me tell you we can't [ __ ]
this up we slice through that Wellington
it's gotta be pink
let's go guys please nervous a bit and
they were really cooks for people
outside my family and
forty-year-old David Jones is one of my
best chefs but after leaving the army he
got addicted to heroin
you know I have been coming in and out
of Prisons for a long time now and I see
it as I'm getting old in our life and I
want to change this means a hell of a
lot to me I'm determined not to fail
I wish hapless her Sam showed the same
dedication how sad they actually coming
for lunch tomorrow
yeah not next month yeah let's go rock
up your ass despite my best efforts he
still got a lot to learn
mustard nor the drowning it's just
swimming in the stuff yourself the first
time I ever tried to cook beagle toast
and they're not burning they're my
ex-girlfriends flat fabricated coming
down cookies no any my finger it's gotta
be firm guys really tomorrow I need
everyone pulling together so I've
decided to pair up weaker team members
like Hassan with the older wiser heads
auntie to bond work as a team David
Jones you're working with us and gnaw on
your table you have the head of one of
the most successful catering companies
in the country you have some very
serious individuals that you need to
impress better a marvel system are
tomorrow's volunteer
reformed junkie David Jones isn't happy
he's working with drug dealer Hassan
I'll start to put some of it exid are
tomorrow
it's key ball to the level we'll start
life I'm used to
you know understanded that i want so i
don't want a full thirty-minute than a
dinner
yep I'm David Joyce - yeah David in a
bit yeah no way yeah I can't afford any
passengers during tomorrow's big launch
everyone needs to perform including her
sad
so I've come over to a wing to make sure
he's got a message Hey two minutes I
don't want anyone to blow it tomorrow
yeah and you're in it at all but I don't
want David Jones you know doing all your
work no no I want you to step up because
you don't want that when you put your
head down you're good you can you can
focus if tomorrow goes to plan it's that
big opportunity to impress the people
who can put the slice in their stores
and make it a success this is the
potential heartbeat of the future
business inside this prison and then the
guys are up against it they are gonna be
under immense pressure cooking serving
restaurant quality food it sounds like a
[ __ ] recipe for disaster
I just hope we can put off